- I have no agenda here
to tell you this, but,
I had never met you until
just a few moments ago.
- Yeah.
- But,
you come across, on television,
as exactly as you are,
as full of joy
and you will have a career
as long as you want one
in this business.
(audience cheering)
'Cause people see you on television,
they see you on television,
you can't, you can't
look at your personality
and not be joyful.
It's happening, you don't
get depressed looking at you,
with me, people go to the other room.
- No, with you they start chanting
until you can't be. (laughing)
- Yeah. (laughing)
- That's my favorite part.
- Yeah. (chuckling)
- Wait, you also made a movie?
- And so did you, fancy pants.
- Mm-hmm, and mine is
contractual obligated,
it was horrible.
How was yours?
- Horrible.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Radsies for the both of us.
- Yeah.
- What was your movie about?
- What was my movie about?
- Yeah.
- It was about two hours.
It was about two hours
too long, is what it was.
No, it was called "Ringmaster"
and it came out right when my show was
really doing well.
- Oh.
- And so they wanted me
to make a movie about it,
"Ringmaster", because it's
a circus, my show, so,
and that's what we did.
I never made a movie before, so,
when I started doing the movie,
then I would joke around,
I'd say, "Now, when are the Oscars?"
So I got a buddy of mine to
write an acceptance speech
for me.
- Oh my gosh.
- 'Cause I was confident.
But he wrote the speech and
the first thing in the speech
is, "I'd like to thank
my wife, Connie Chung."
(audience groaning)
(Kelly laughing)
I love Maury, but I'm not Maury.
(audience laughing)